Hello, and thank you for joining us today.
I am with Phil Estes, a distinguished engineer
at IBM and also the maintainer of the
containerd
project. Hello, Phil. Thank you for joining us.
How are you? Great. Yeah. Glad to be
here.
Thanks for having me on.
No. This is awesome. Containerd
is one of those projects where I am
familiar with it exists. I am familiar that
I'm using it in production,
and I don't really know much more about
it beyond that. So I'm looking forward today
to getting into some of the details of
how containerd works and why it exists.
Awesome. Yeah.
Excellent.
So I think
let's just start with
a viewer question because I think it is
important, and I may already have made my
first mistake of the stream. But this person
asked on Reddit prior,
how do I pronounce it? Is it containerd
or is it containerd?
Yeah. So
the project,
officially, we we call it containerd,
but it's definitely been an inside joke or
not so inside joke that we call each
other containers.
So, yeah, officially, the project name is definitely
containerd,
Thinking, you know, how systemd and other daemon
like processes
are
are called. That's kind of the the nomenclature.
Right. See, that's sometimes you just don't think
about that, but I think it's so prevalent,
especially, you know, in the technology community. We
have so many projects where
you don't always know the right way to
see it. You know, we always have these
weird debates around, is it MySQL or MySQL
and all this stuff. So I think it's
good to be clear clear that up for
sure. Yep.
Alright. Do you wanna if you don't mind,
just give us a little bit of a
backstory then. How did containerd
come to exist?
Yeah.
So,
you know, I think the the easiest
starting point is to think about, you know,
Docker's rise as a developer tool,
you know, that 2014,
'20 '15 era.
It was really easy to use and install
because, essentially,
that single binary,
at least, you know, speaking in Linux terms,
you know, there wasn't Docker desktop. There weren't
all these other products around it. It was
just Docker. And Docker, the tool,
could easily be put on any Linux system.
It was statically linked. You didn't have to
worry about your distributor
giving you the right version linked to the
right libraries.
And it was sort of an all in
one tool. It had registry support. It had
ability to build containers. It ran containers.
And, obviously, you know, over those next few
years, there was an explosion of features,
and,
there was also,
you know, some community tensions around when Swarm
got added and Kubernetes was coming on the
scene or effectively was already there, but rising
in significance and usage.
Out of all that, you know, you also
had people with other ideas for what a
container runtime should look like.
And so out of that, the OCI was
born, so the open container initiative.
So
most people,
you know, may know this, but at
from about 2015 on,
Docker or other container engines that are OCI
compliant
rarely are actually doing the execution of your
contained process.
That's left to a binary called run c
of of open source project maintained by the
OCI.
And so
as soon as run c sort of came
on the scene and Docker started using run
c,
Michael Crosby and some others inside Docker
built this kind of shim layer between the
full Docker engine and run c, and that
was the initial containerd code base.
If you look back in our GitHub GitHub
history, you'll see a branch zero dot two
dot x.
That's the code base that
effectively was that
start of containerd
back in that era.
So containerd at the time was really a
a runtime manager.
So Docker said, you know, hey. Somebody called
Docker run.
Containerd, can you go start a run c
process? Here's all the details.
It builds the OCI spec,
you know, which declares things like which binary
am I running, which namespaces am I using,
you know, any c groups. So all these
configuration
details
that, if you're a developer, you think of
those are flags like on Docker run, you
know, things I wanna change to this user
or, you know, add this volume mount. All
that ended up passing down through these layers
and containerd effectively managed that run c layer.
So, again, kinda skipping a lot of exciting
history in the container ecosystem at that at
that time.
You know, you can go back and find
tweets and blog posts. You know, Docker is
getting too big. Swarm is competing with Kubernetes.
And so,
you know, cloud providers like IBM and others
were talking to Docker about, you know, maybe
it is time for a more kind of
stable
core runtime. You know, Docker has storage plug
ins and registry features and an enterprise product,
you know, maybe we can segment out just
that core runtime
idea
into its own
into its own layer. And so containerd effectively
moved from that zero dot two branch to
the one o
sort of release
time time frame in late twenty sixteen.
And that became the more full
container runtime that if you install containerd today,
if you do the latest one four o
or or you're using Docker, which I think
over the weekend updated to one three seven.
You know, this this
version of containerd is now
has, you know, full image support to push
and pull images.
It's not just a runtime manager, but it
handles the content
and the task management and
metadata and all those things so that it
can be a full run time underneath Kubernetes,
which is probably the most popular use case
for containerd.
But there's still millions of Docker engines that
use containerd under the covers,
again, to manage that run c
layer of, the actual processes being contained.
So, yeah, that's the whirlwind tour. You can
find some talks on YouTube about, you know,
what is containerd, where did it come from,
and maybe a little more of that history.
But
that's kind of the the quick version.
Excellent. You actually answered another viewer question there
as part of that kind of summary there.
There's
another question from Reddit was why does containerd
exist when Docker, you know, was a thing
even though they understood that Docker now uses
containerd? And I think the answer there as
well, this was at least in the initial
version was spun out of Docker to simplify
that runtime aspect.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Okay. So,
I mean, as far as containerd
goes and and as touch points with the
container ecosystem, you you've mentioned Docker there. So
Docker uses containerd to actually orchestrate or run
the containers. Kubernetes now uses containerd as as
the default runtime implementation.
Are there is there anything missing there that
we haven't covered? Is containerd used in any
other large substantial projects that that's worth mentioning?
Yeah. So
the
I I think yeah. There's two aspects that
I I'm
stumbling because I there there's a couple aspects
to that. There's because containerd
really
has a
a API layer that's been very attractive. There's
a lot of sort of consuming of containerd
across a
pretty large number of projects that
aren't necessarily just using it as a runtime,
but consuming it,
in some other way,
or expanding on its capabilities because
many parts of the architecture are pluggable.
So I think you know? So what what
aspect of this whole thing is we could
talk about all the cloud Kubernetes services that
use it by default. We've already mentioned that.
Linux kit, which a project that came out
of Docker,
kind of a containerized,
you know, minimal secure Linux uses containerd as
the core runtime.
A lot of the
sort of lightweight hypervisor
or other
advanced isolation
capabilities like Amazon's firecracker project or cata containers.
They've built shims. When we look at the
architecture, we'll we'll see what that means. But
they've built shims so that you can, again,
drive containerd through its API or from Kubernetes.
And you can use these custom, you know,
isolation engines,
gVisor,
again, another option there. And then
Cloud Foundry
used to have a run c management
layer,
and they've effectively
switched to use containerd.
So, again, Cloud Foundry is a pass
like Heroku,
and so that's another kind of major user.
And then, you know, there's just a a
set of various vendor projects. So Alibaba Cloud
built
a tool called pouch container, which is almost
like a a Swiss army knife, docker like
container runtime that, again, embeds containerd
and exposes all these features that Alibaba Cloud
uses
on their platform.
And then Rancher did something similar
when they built
k three s.
So this kind of minimize Kubernetes.
Darren chose to build containerd directly into k
three s. So you don't even use a
separate containerd binary.
Containerd is the run time for k three
s, and it's built directly into that single
binary. So
and then, you know, I guess one more
that comes to mind, Alex Ellis built FASD.
So, again, part of his open FASD
hierarchy of projects. FASD
gives you a way to you know, you
could deploy open FASD as Kubernetes
based deployment,
but you can also run FASD and you're
just effectively using the containerd runtime
to run your functions
as a service
in containers.
So yeah. That you know, I'm probably missing
some, but that's you know, people seem to
be happy to kind of explore how to
embed containerd in other projects because of this
simple kind of API layer.
Actually, one one other project that's worth mentioning
because you may already be using it, the
build kit, which again is an open source
project out of Docker.
If you're using a very recent Docker, I'm
not sure if they've made the switch where
build kit is default,
but it will be soon.
But, again, a a a
container build engine that uses containerd's API under
the covers and can build directly with containerd
without Docker at all.
So, yeah, those that's a handful of kinda
containerd using or
exploiting projects.
That was a lot.
There's a lot there.
Is now a good time then where we
pull up this architecture diagram and you can
give us the the quick tour of some
of those things you were talking about as
well? Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely.
Alright. There we go.
Yeah. Look at all the boxes.
So let I I think
one reason why, you know, this particular image
is useful is you can kinda see ways
that
various tools kinda insert themselves of various layers
of the containerd architecture.
One thing to note here
that is important is that
the containerd architecture, that core layer in the,
I guess, greenish, light greenish color,
is actually built as a unique
or differentiated
set of gRPC driven services.
So all these services could be used by
themselves. And the reason that's important is that
there are people who have written libraries or
uses of containerd
that replace,
you know, a specific service so that you
can use, you know, this construct
even outside of using the containerd daemon altogether.
So,
you know, or as I don't maybe some
listeners have heard of or as out of
the desk labs team at Microsoft,
but they liked the simplicity by which you
could use the Go API for containerd to
talk to a registry.
But they didn't want the content service
to be writing or to writing to containerd's
content store, which you would need the containerd
daemon running.
So they just were you can make these
calls and say, actually, my content service is
just this place in memory over here or
this file system.
And now you can write a library
that uses a piece of containerd
to do registry interaction, but you don't need
the containerd daemon at all.
So there's all kinds of uses where
any one of these GRP services, so the
content, diff, images, leases, namespaces,
all these services are available. You should call
them directly via gRPC,
or you could write your own implementation and
and tell containerd,
actually, no. Here's my implementation of content or
containers or tasks.
Most people aren't gonna wanna do that. They're
just gonna use it. They're gonna go a
layer up. So then containerd has an API
where it simplifies talking and and meshing these
services together. So you can think of,
like, using it from Kubernetes through the CRI.
So that's that left block of the containerd
API.
You're calling
the it's using a containerd client go API
to do things like run a container, pull
an image, and all those services are used
by that API
to do that.
And, if you know about if you've ever
configure configured the Docker engine with a specific
graph driver,
like, oh, I use overlay or I use
device mapper,
We call those snapshatters
in containerd lingo.
And so, again, we support a lot of
the same ones you've seen before,
but it's also pluggable. And that's interesting in
that
If you don't like any of these snapshatters,
you can write your own, and there's some
very interesting work.
There's a talk from KubeCon a few weeks
ago on the star g z snapshot, which
does lazy image pull and anyway, it can
do major speed up in container startup time.
So having the snapshot or be pluggable means
you're not limited by the ones that we've
thought up
or implemented.
And it allows things like, you know, Windows
to use their own snapshot or their own
implementations
that
Microsoft has written.
Stepping to the right of that, when you
actually run a container, I talked about shims.
You know, obviously, the most natural shim is
to call run c. I'm on Linux. I
just want Linux kernel based containers.
I just want run c to run my
process with the isolation I specify.
But because our shim API is pluggable and
you can extend it and configure your own,
This is where you see Cata containers or
Firecracker
or gVisor
or on my on Windows, the run HCS
tool
or or shim that Microsoft has built to
run
Linux containers on Windows as well as Windows
containers on Windows.
So, yeah, we've got so the shims are
down there at the bottom. We've talked about
Snapshotters,
the pluggable content store,
the array of gRPC services.
And then, of course, above that,
you know, you can have container engines consuming
all of this by using the the Go
library
or calling the API.
And so Docker does that. The pouch container
project I talked about does that,
via the CRI API.
Kubernetes does that.
And then build kit, again, another consumer who
also just says, I wanna use containerd as
a client. I'm gonna use the Go API
to use their features for
pushing and pulling from registries,
and so on. And then we have a
simple administrative client called CTR
on the far right there of the client.
And that's,
I think, the most important point for developers
is we don't really expect that to be
a replacement for the Docker command line.
The Docker command line, of course, has grown
over the years to have
lots and lots of features.
We're not seeing containerd as a replacement for
a direct kind of developer workflow.
So CTR
will probably feel clunky in some ways to
to a developer who's used to the docker
workflow.
And there's a purpose to that because it's
not really meant to be a replacement for
your day to day use. It's more administrative
debug
so that, you know, you can test out
containerd,
But we expect you're probably using it via
some other wrapping
tool like a platform. So that top layer,
I'm using
Azure's
Kubernetes service. I'm using Docker.
I'm using Rancher's k three s. You know,
all the all these use cases don't require
me to to use containerd as kind of
my main development tool,
but containerd is there providing,
the platform,
for these tools to then have a easy
API for
a container runtime.
And so that that's kind of the end
result of what we talked about with the
the history
is that containerd is kind of the stable
layer
that gives you all those features,
but really is not meant to be a
replacement
for the developer workflow.
So, yeah, I I hope I did it
justice. There's a lot a lot there, but
that's
that's the bulk of of how it's assembled
and what the pieces are.
Yes. You definitely did that justice.
I think I'm just in complete
not shocked, but maybe all. Just the size
and breadth of the of the project, you
know, and previously when I've always thought about
containerd, I think of the cube blitz telling
containerd to go run a container for me
and it being such a small API surface.
But, really, there's a lot of moving parts
and a lot of things that can be
swapped in. I mean, just looking at the,
you the containerdish shims there, moving between run
c and maybe kinda containers or firecracker. Like,
a lot of flexibility in this architecture that,
I guess, is why people are adopting it
for their own tooling.
I you know, I think,
you know, we've gotten a lot of positive
comments about the API over the last couple
years. You know,
when Alex came and said, hey. Let's you
know, can you help me figure out how
I might use containerd underneath FASD?
We've worked as used it underneath a few
of their projects.
And,
you know, there there's always a learning curve.
It's like, oh, I didn't expect it to
work this way. And and I
think there's another question
that you got about documentation,
which we can talk a little bit more
about. But, you know, it's hard to
as a small team of maintainers to to
cover all the use cases and make sure
everybody has the information they need
to
consume containerd. But in general, you're absolutely right
that people that have dug in a little
bit say, hey. This is actually really easy
to provide all the features I need
for,
you know, embedding or utilizing a container runtime
of my project,
and it just works. It's stable. It it's
simple. And and
so, yeah, we're pretty happy with
the comments we've gotten from people that that
have ended up using it for their project.
Excellent. I'm gonna quote you that when anyone
ever asked me how difficult is it to
integrate containerdames with a project. It's be Phil
said this is easy. That's that's difficult.
Do you see a future where
more
I I don't wanna say something's gonna try
to replace Docker as, a developer tool, but
do see more people using containerd as base
for developer tooling? You know, I know a
lot of people are frustrated with, you know,
local development tooling for Kubernetes. And do you
see containerd be in the API that people
start to adopt for things like that?
Yeah. I I would hesitate
thinking that containerd will will fully replace
those kind of workflows. I I again, we
see it as a
more as an embeddable
runtime.
You know, I mean, a couple of comments
like
I think the
there are a lot of people on Macs,
for example. There there's people using Windows and
WSL two.
And so, you know, because containerd is a
Linux
focused project,
and, of course, we have Windows support as
well,
You know, you're
you know, unless we find people who
who really wanna dig in and build kind
of another layer around it, you're not gonna
get the ease of, like, Docker desktop.
You know, where on my Mac, I've got
this sort of streamlined.
It feels like I'm running Docker commands on
my, you know, Mac terminal prompt, and I'm
pulling images.
You know, all those
all that ecosystem doesn't exist for containerd. So
if you're a Linux only developer
and you're,
you know, building on a sort of Kubernetes
ecosystem layer,
then CTR as a tool may be enough
for, like, what you wanna do.
Because, you know, quickly, you're gonna go from
CTR to using kubectl,
you know, for actually doing
deployments or or your Kubernetes based work. So
yeah. I'm I'm rambling a little, but I
think, you know, I I don't see containerd
really ever being that full kind of Docker
ecosystem replacement.
Because, again, Docker is more than just the
container runtime these days anyway.
You know, one thing we haven't said officially
here is that there is no CTR build.
So you're gonna either need build kit or
you're need Docker
or some in cloud, you know, CICD build
service to actually take docker files or whatever
your input is to build containers. Containerd has
no
container assembly
code build code in it.
Alright. Got it. So
there was a a talk you gave at
KubeCon
a couple of weeks ago, and there was
a slightly different version of the of the
architecture diagram.
Yeah. Is there anything here we should we
should cover?
Yeah. It's it's a good question. I I'm
gonna I'm getting old, so I'm gonna put
on my glasses and make sure I can
read this.
So the yeah. This is
kind of a a it's almost the same
view turned on its side,
and it's trying to give a little more
functional
I mean, we're trying to make it clear,
like, how the pieces actually connect together.
And so the client has been expanded, and
we've kinda taken out the consumer part of
it.
So you can see, like, the client now
helps you see how do I actually access,
you know, what's behind this. You know, how
do I
you know, so I configure my client with
some options. How do I connect to the
gRPC socket?
I subscribe to events.
I
you know, for containers themselves, I pass in
options. I get an OCI spec.
And then these proxies, that's that's the actual
gRPC traffic
across that boundary to the containerd one dot
x API.
And so that kinda you know, it it
looks duplicated, but that's that helps you see
that, like, on my client side,
when I say CTR run,
that task service
will talk to the the task API
and then use the actual implementation
on the server side,
which could use a
you know, it's gonna use the images and
snapshots
service
to assemble the right root file system to
actually call the task manager to start a
shim if I'm using run c by default.
So this view,
you know, is easier to talk through the
flow of, like, how does, you know, CTR
run actually turn into a series of steps
that gets me a running run c shim
at the at the far right side.
But there you know, as far as the
API,
the the great news for consumers is, like,
we have not had to break that gRPC
API
for two years now.
And so we hope we hope that this
API is extremely stable
that
if people need functional differences,
they shouldn't be coming to us and say,
hey. Please change the containerd API.
They should be looking at the pluggability of
this core
and saying, oh, I could do that. You
know, I need a different shim because I'm
trying to do some fancy thing at the
runtime level,
or I need a plug in for snapshots
because I want a new way to, like,
represent
the file system.
Or I have this cool file system that
you guys don't know about in my lab,
and I want to utilize it with a
snapshot or
so, yeah, the
I think the main point of this is
that
actually, one more comment. The API layer, you
see the CRI plug in.
So one thing I didn't mention in the
history is that containerd was initially built without
an implementation
for Kubernetes
CRI, which is the container runtime interface.
So that is a separate gRPC API defined
by the Kubernetes community.
If you're interested,
SIGNode
is the Kubernetes
special interest group that deals with the CRI
API,
and it does evolve over time.
So
a set of sort of
separate maintainers built a CRI plug in for
containerd,
and so you can find two different
GitHub projects. We brought them in to the
containerd repository
several years ago,
but we're now actually
for Kubernetes I'm sorry. For containerd one dot
five, we plan on actually bringing their code
into containerd, and so this plug in continues
to get more tightly integrated.
So if you're using containerd one two, one
three, one four,
that binary does have the CRI plug in
built in.
The code base change is just to continue
that natural progression of
we're all maintaining the same code. We're all
working together, so the CRI doesn't need to
be a separate project anymore.
So, again, that just
by default, that gives us a
makes us a Kubernetes runtime. The Kubelet can
talk to the same gRPC socket and talk
that CRI API
directly to containerd.
So yeah.
Excellent. I think
there's definitely a lot to unpack there with,
you know, both architectural diagrams and the different
components.
And really cool that that kind of CRI
layer and the API layer are maybe gonna
consolidate.
Does that mean
that containerd then becomes a competitor with with
cryo?
Yeah. I
I always try and be careful when I
you know, I think a lot of a
lot of folks wanna see
kinda sparks fly between containerd and creo.
You know, creo is
really
had a similar vision to
containerd
and that Red Hat
and Docker had, you know, some
some competitive
disagreements over
Docker's
kind of future,
definitely around swarm
and, you know, other issues around distributing
Docker and Red Hat
distributions of Linux.
And so Creo had the same idea of
kind of this core runtime built on some
building blocks.
And so if you go look on GitHub,
you can see a project containers slash storage.
That's actually a copy of the Docker graph
drivers implementation
from, like, old Docker one twelve, one 13
era.
And then Red Hat continued to develop it
and, of of course, officially maintains it today
as an open source project under that containers
repo.
So there's container storage and containers image.
And what you'll see is that Red Hat
has built a layer of tools on top
of those two projects.
So it's not just Creo, it's Podman
and Builda
and Scorpio.
They all use the same layer, and that
gives them
the ability to say, hey. Our tools are
actually
not dependent on a daemon
because they're all using the same container container
storage file store.
They're all using this container's image library
for talking to registries.
And so all of this can happen, like,
kind of in the tool itself.
Creo is is not necessarily daemonless in the
sense that
the Kubelet has to have a CRI socket
to talk to. So you have to have
some listener
somewhere.
And so Creo does have, you know, these
small daemons that listen for the CRI API
and to do some monitoring of the processes.
But, you know, it's it's really
born out of the same time frame as
containerd.
And,
you know, as a a a very personal
comment, not representing IBM or Red Hat or
Docker,
You know, there was definitely,
personally, a hope that that we could rally
around one or the other. And, of course,
naturally,
containerd was my intention to to convince them
to work together on that. And the the
cool thing is that we've shared code over
the years.
They import some of our sub packages
and use containerd code for some things.
And so, you know,
at the maintainer level, you know, we've always
had good relationship and work together.
But to me, it's I hope it's becoming
more like, you know, some people use Firefox,
some people use Chrome,
you know, maybe on a Mac, you like
Safari. You know, these aren't
they are competitive in in a general sense
that you have to make a choice about
which kind of community you're gonna use or
get involved in, but they're just options. They're
just options that are out there. And, yes,
there are some differences in
kind of the design,
but that that's where I see it today.
Alright. Awesome.
It's
great context there just to understand how those
two projects fit. And, you know, with the
CRI there and the OCI stuff, like, the
compatibility is there for people to Exactly. Have
preference.
Yep. So we have one more question, and
then I think what we'll do is we
jump onto the hands on component of this
session. And the question came from Reddit again,
and it was, what are some best practices
while running containerd via systemd?
That's that seems like a way a wide
scope, so I'll let you if you want
to
Yeah. Go back to that. Yeah. Hopefully, I'll
answer the right question because
there's not really
like, I'm not sure if they're asking if
there's kind of a strong integration with, like,
the way systemd manages
processes
because, you know, there are
there have been methods.
And and I know some people still use
these where, you know, systemd is much more
integrated in actually the spawning and management of
container processes.
That's not the case with containerd. So,
you know, we have
we have in our repo, and I believe
it's delivered in our full
release tarball,
a systemd unit for containerd. And that just
means that, you know, containerd will be started
on boot, you know, with other system processes.
At that point, that's that's really the last
sort of interconnection
with system d. There's no other management
other than the way system d manages,
you know, units on the system. You can
start it. You can check its status, etcetera.
So I I don't know if that's the
question being asked, but today, that's kind of
our
our interaction with systemd is if you're on
a systemd
controlled
Linux distribution,
then containerd's
unit will make sure that containerd is started
and and
but containerd at that point will manage its
own
processes that are run via containerd. There won't
be any integration with systemd as far as
the spotting of containers
at that point.
Okay.
So just a question that popped in my
head then as you were kinda talking about
that.
Are there any rules around restarting the containerd
process about how that would affect running containers,
or does it pretty similar?
Yeah. It's
yeah.
There shouldn't be any issues with with restart
similar to how over the years Docker
matured to where
it's not gonna crash all your containers. You're
not gonna lose state. You know, containerd will
restart and try and reconnect to the shims.
So that's one of the reasons the shims
exist. The shims are the parent
of your actual containerized process.
And so if containerd goes away,
the shims, thankfully, are still parented.
I I mean, it's still parenting your
container, so it's it's not gonna wipe out
I don't know if people remember. In the
early days of Docker, you crash your Docker
daemon, you lose all your containers.
That's not the case. So containerd can restart.
It'll go find all the shims,
and you should
you know, unless there's a bug or some
other complicated issue, you'll still have access and
and management of the containers that we're already
running.
Nice.
Alright. Let me share my screen then and
we'll kinda
let's let's actually play with this. Right? So
what I have in front of me
is a Linux machine unpack it because I
run a Mac and that's not gonna work.
So
I have got snap installed
and I went ahead
and ran snap install Michael Kates classic.
I have done this your advice as you
said that Michael Kates gives us access to
the containerd
tooling as well as access to containerd running
as the CRI implementation for Kubernetes.
So that's all I've done. I've not done
anything else.
What do I do now? Yeah.
So
yeah. In the in true Internet fashion, we're
flying by the seat of our pants because
I haven't messed with microcates in a little
bit. But
but just to give people a quick flavor,
this is Canonical's
kind of like kind.
People have used kind
where you you kind of have a single
node Kubernetes
distribution
all in one, which means, of course, you've
got the Kubelet. You have
your your single node is now everything. You're
the master. You've got a Kubelet. You have
a container runtime.
And it just so happens that microcates uses
containerd as their runtime.
And so we should, at this point, have
a running
containerd,
and we should have the CTR
tool available to us. So,
yeah, for Lucky, this should show us
yeah. So we can see the path there
is inside this snap of microcates.
It has its own, varlib containerd,
and that seems to be running.
And,
yeah, we can actually see some shims because,
again, this is a Kubernetes deployment.
So there are actually some containers.
As you know, if you start up Kubernetes,
you have some some system
cube system containers, pods that are already up
and running. So
I don't know. Yeah. Go ahead. So based
on what I kinda picked up then on
on the API surface of containerd is that
I should although we're not recommending it as
a, like, you know, daily driver, be able
to pull an image and and run a
container using
CTR.
Yeah. So let's see if CTR is in
your path. I can't remember if you have
to do microkates.ctr
or
Yeah. You you you do. But I do
have access to CTR. So Okay. Yeah. Great.
One of the things we should talk about
at this point is that containerd,
unlike
the sort of default docker
model, is that every
every
bit of content and metadata is namespaced.
And so maybe do a CTR space namespaces
l s
or or n s works as well.
So you can see that there's already a
kates dot I o, and this means that
that micro kates deployment is actually whenever it
runs containers
through the CRI,
they're getting
placed in this kates.i0
namespace.
It's kinda cool because now if we use
CTR from the command line and we don't
wanna mess Now, again, there's not this is
really administrative. There's no security being applied here.
There's no RBAC. That's all handled at higher
layers.
But we can do
we can basically create a new namespace.
So we we can create one called default
or Rawkode.
I think it's just create and then a
name. Yeah. I'm just assuming that that was
gonna work. So
Okay. So now if we do the l
s, we have Rawkode.
Now every other command takes a dash n
or a dash dash namespace,
which gets really
annoying to type. So if you export the
containerd
underscore namespace equals Rawkode
environment
into the environment, then,
basically
now if we do a a micro k
CTR
containers or or just c by itself, l
s.
We'll see
now why do we see containers?
I was about to say we shouldn't see
anything because we've exported our namespace.
Did I mess up the export?
It looks right. Container d namespace.
So let's try
just bring back the CLS command and preface
it
with dash
before the c.
Just do dash
n Rawkode.
And what did I do wrong? Oh, connect
two forms of the same flag.
Does that mean it's reading the environment?
Yeah. Yeah. That's what I'm kinda getting from.
Yeah.
Interesting. I
I
yeah. That's fun. I I can't think of
why you're seeing.
Yeah. I think
CLS
should be
namespaced.
Oh, you know what?
The I think we're having fun with micro
case doing something
default
behind our backs. I think they're I think
they're setting the namespace
for us so that
so that we get the microcates environment.
Okay. That makes sense. Yeah. So that's kind
of fun. I don't know if there's a
way to to tell micro case not to
do that, but that we can still play
around. We don't Yeah. We'll just ignore it.
Yeah. We'll ignore it. Yeah.
So, yeah, that's the fun of using somebody's
sort of
embodiment. So, yeah, these are the pods that
are running, you know, via
the microcades environment. So we can let's pull
our own image. So So can I ask
you a question? Yeah.
So is the part a native concept in
containerd rather than a container?
No. So,
again, we implement the CRI,
which has some of those concepts, but it
doesn't require the runtime itself to to
have those concepts in its own. So there
if if you go back and look at
that architecture diagram, it just thinks in tasks
and containers.
There's nothing on here that says there's no
med data type called upon.
And
so it's really the CRI plug in that
that that has the knowledge that, oh, these
two containers are in the same pod, so
I need to share the network
namespace and UTS namespace,
etcetera.
So, yeah, containerd's
core code base does not have the pod
concept.
Okay. Perfect.
Yeah. So,
I guess, just to show the poll and
run scenario,
we can do CTR
images,
and then it's pull.
And the only difference between, like, the way
you do it in Docker is you need
to you need to fully specify,
so there's no default to Docker Hub.
So you need to preface that with docker
dot I o
slash library
because it's actually the core library
slash n's in NGINX, and you have to
add a tag. Like, we don't let you
do
the so cold latest is fine.
So you fully specify the the exact image.
It's gonna pull the layers,
and it will unpack the one for your
architecture if it's a multi platform image. So
it's a okay. Your Linux AMD sixty four,
and now you have that image locally. And
so you can do a CTR images l
s
just to kinda see.
And it it's a little messy because it's
showing a lot of detail around the architectures
that are supported,
the media type of the image.
Again,
you know A large font would be helping
either. Yeah. Yeah. So
but if you if, you know, it's hard
to see in here, but if you've grabbed
on your NGINX, you'd you'd see that, you
know, we've officially pulled
the NGINX latest. Yep.
And that it was a multi arc image.
It supports all those platforms, but it only
unpacked
the
Linux AMD sixty four image.
So now we can run it.
And the way we do that is just
a CTR.
We actually have a simplified
run command, but, yeah, container run
works.
Actually, yeah, run run, you don't need to
specify kind of the the object type. So
CTR run by itself without the container.
Do I need to fill
Yeah. No.
You don't have to fill all that.
Actually,
yes. You do. I'm sorry.
Let's just see if I break it then.
Yeah. Yeah.
Oh, I need a container ID.
Yeah. So you have to name your container.
We don't have the fancy fun, like, default
name like Docker.
So
I feel it would be remiss if I
didn't give it a name and it's been,
though. So let's call it angry Linus.
I think yeah. So there's no
it actually just takes positional parameters. So you
the dash end isn't needed. So just give
it
I'm trying to think if there's an order
here that I'm forgetting.
So the image
and then the
there is a default command. You don't need
to specify command in args.
So the ID is the last. So
what did you get an error? I was
I missed it.
You should just be able to specify a
name after the the image.
Oh, but you'll need the
you'll need the docker I o slash library
in front of NGINX.
Alright.
But, again, it it there's no default to
Docker Hub.
Alright.
You're get oh, you're a pseudo. Well, that's
fun.
You are as root.
Still weird
micro case thing, probably.
Yeah.
But I'm
again,
they may they may
have made some changes in micro case to
kind of keep you on the farm, like,
not off running random images.
So I yeah. I'm sorry. I I should've
messed around with that too because I I
I will take credit or
or the fall for recommending that we use
microcades just as a simple way to get
containerd.
Alright. Let's just snap
on install microcades.
What's the numbers? Remove.
Spell it right. We'll
get there. And then I just we'll just
do a curl get dot docker dot I
o. Yeah. That that'll that'll give us a
containerd
instance that's our that should actually start it
for us as well.
No. It's not faster than moving things, is
it?
Yeah. It it actually has to stop the
Kubelet and the container engine and stop a
bunch of pods, and it tries to do
it.
I guess I don't really need it to
go away, so let's just
yeah. I mean, the snap is actually not
gonna get in the way of the standard
containerd.
Well, it's not it's not listening to my
wonderful signal. So
I will grab
this IP address, and I'll just
that's it.
That's the same one.
Course, it comes back. Right? Right.
So curl,
it should be at
get dot docker dot I o.
And we'll just
okay. Let's just save it.
Have I got that wrong?
Get.DockerIO.
I just copy it from here.
Get off there.
There we go. There you go.
Yeah. So that's interesting. I I
was
chatting with the microcades folks now and then
and and seeing if I could use it
for kind of as a standalone containerd,
but that's it's been a while. So maybe
something
has changed with that.
Alright.
Yeah. I
mean, I I've used micro kits a few
times. It usually works pretty well. I'm sure
it's just something silly. But we can
quickly get back to where we were. So
we've built the engine with latest image. And
in theory, now I should be able to
do
run,
and it was Docker
IO library
engine next
latest and then angry
wireless.
Ta da.
Yep. There we go.
So
a couple things
that are worth mentioning. So
that can be disappointing for folks.
You know, Docker defaulted
or had a default implementation
of
an a core kind of networking implementation
because containerd was built in the context of
just, again, this core,
like, run an OCI image,
you know, take the spec,
create the right namespaces.
There's no default, like,
IP forwarding,
bridge, all those pieces that people kind of
expect out of the box because Docker had
it. Kubernetes
doesn't need that, right, because you've got a
CNI plug in providing the that networking layer.
So this NGINX we just built, there's no
way to, like, talk to it
because there's no IP address in this container
you just started.
There are some fun tools people have written.
You can kinda add that on your own.
You can mess around with that.
Or, again, you can use it via
another layer,
and you get that to however that other
layer provides it. So,
you know, if people wanna play around with
that, Michael Crosby has a a nifty tool
called BOSS,
b o s s,
that
wraps containerd,
add some
management. I think he runs, like, his kind
of personal network services and and
system using BOSS.
It has some nice restart and checkpoint features.
So, again,
containerd
is
really built as something you build on top
of. And so there are things that just
don't come out of the box such as
networking by default.
Yeah. I was gonna say, like, you know,
you said earlier, and you've kind of we
said it again there. This is not a
tool for people sitting in front of a
computer that wanna run containers. And I was
thinking, but CTR run wasn't that bad, and
then that
there's no networking. There's no volume system.
Maybe
not something I wanna do then.
Yeah.
Yeah. And then, again,
with the CRI plug in as being one
of our primary use cases,
you know, you can think, well,
if I put that in containerd, I'd be
duplicating things that the Kubernetes layer already does
for me.
And so that's some of the thinking behind
that is,
you know, I don't need those features because
the layer above me is gonna provide those.
And, you know,
it it it's a it's a good point,
especially for that Kubernetes use case because
I know for a fact that,
it becomes a security issue to some consumers
of Kubernetes services
when they find out, oh, you use Docker
as the Kubernetes runtime.
What do you do with the Docker default
bridge? Because it's not it shouldn't be used,
but it's there because Docker created it when
it when the daemon started.
And so
people that use the Docker engine as a
Kubernetes runtime,
you may be asked in a security audit,
you know, have you removed the Docker bridge
because, you know, your containers are being connected
potentially to two different networks,
the Kubernetes CNI implementation you use,
but also the Docker default bridge.
So, again, not having that in containerd is
one less thing that you have to monkey
with
because there's no default kind of network implementation.
Right.
Got it. So we're approaching the the hour
now, and we have a few more questions
that were submitted via Reddit and Twitter,
which I'll I'll run through if you're happy
to, and then we'll we'll wrap up for
for there for the day. I think that's
great. So
the first question I have now is how
do I debug containerd issues? Which log files
should I look in, and how do I
fix it?
Yeah. So if you're in charge of running
containerd,
the daemon, there
is a log level setting
that if you do, you know, dash d
on containerd,
you go into deep debug mode and you
get
significant volumes of
of information
on events,
the
API, on registry interactions.
So,
obviously, if if you're able to
to restart the daemon, reproduce your issue in
debug mode,
that's almost always a a valuable source of,
you know, what happened? Why didn't this happen?
What what was the error? Why did the
daemon say my container couldn't start or the
OCI runtime
So that that's kind of step one, run
your daemon in debug mode. Gonna be a
little trickier if you're a consumer of something
that's using containerd,
how do you get them to turn containerd
into debug mode? So that that may be
a secondary thing you have to figure out.
If
again, that that
depending on your your setup, where that actually
logs when you're in in debug mode.
You know,
as a as a developer of containerd, I'm
just running containerd
in a separate terminal,
you know, either piping to a file. But
if you're running via systemd,
you should be able to
extract the logs
using the journal, you know, commands for system
d.
If that's not
producing the information you need, say you have
a hang, you know, containerd seems to not
be responding to the API.
Similar to Docker and other tools written in
Go,
you can send a sig user one.
And if there's actually a keystroke you you
can do if if, again, if you're running
containerd in a terminal.
But if you send the signal
and the cool thing is our shim's supported
too. So remember that the shim is a
separate process from the daemon.
You can send both of them a sig
user one and get a full Golang
thread dump process dump.
And a lot of times, you know, we
ask people reporting issues
about hangs or
unresponsive
containerd
to get hub, we ask them to send,
you know, that signal and send us the
the Golang
routine output. And a lot of times, can
see, oh,
your root file system,
like, isn't going away, like, when we're trying
to clean up your container,
and there's another
the shim process is waiting for that to
happen, and it won't return.
So, again, the Golang
output can be really helpful for debugging containerd
as
it's useful for other go go based tools
as well.
So, yeah, that's probably I mean, those two
things are gonna get you 99%
of the way.
People working at a much lower level, you
know, you're building the next gVisor,
kind of containers, and you're down in the
bowels of kernel interactions.
You know, there may be other you know,
obviously,
lots of cool things that are happening with
eBPF
and tools that, you know, track syscalls.
You know, that if you're down at that
layer,
there there are probably a series of tools
that could be valuable
to figure out things like, oh,
there's a seccomp profile blocking my container from
using a certain Cisco. That's why it's not
working.
But that's gonna be more BPF layer related.
Thanks. That was an awesome answer to a
very big question.
So
the next one I'm gonna try and bridge
it for you is is is quite lengthy.
But this what I could the premise of
the question is there seems to be some
discrepancies between a v one and v two
configuration schema. Now I'm not sure what that
is, so maybe you could clarify that. Yep.
But the question is then, are there any
plans to improve the documentation around that so
that there's some those hurdles for people adopting
containerd?
Yeah. That's a good question. So
I'm pretty sure they're referring to
containerd's
TOML configuration
file. So
like most daemons,
you can
run it
with a default config. You don't have ever
have to look at it. It probably is
gonna do you know, when you just installed
Docker and you got CTR and containerds running,
you didn't have to create a config
TOML file
because Docker created one,
containerd started, and you didn't have to worry
about
those settings.
Because
containerd has this plug in model
and there are a series of switches, you
know, turn this on, turn this off.
Over the years, the you know, we chose
TOML. It's very simple,
descriptive language,
you know, has some
similarities to YAML, of course.
But
over time, we found that as we were
adding
features
to containerd,
especially around, like, registry
authorizer support,
like, you know, pull through caches, all all
these kind of fancy configuration options,
and the fact that each plug in can
have its own section in the TOML file.
We found that what we had started with
was just gonna be too
simplistic to handle some of the capabilities we
needed.
And so there's a new TOML format that
the parser in containerd,
if you have version equals two at the
top of your containerd config,
which is now the default,
it will be read,
obviously, as a version two config file
instead of version one. And
I
think the feedback is right on that, like,
maybe we haven't
again, there's a there's a set of users
who will never care about those things and
never have to worry about it.
But for the people that do,
I think it's absolutely correct that we
have struggled to keep up all the documentation
and all the way avenues that people come
to containerd to be able to find
the right documentation
for that version two config.
We do have we've been talking to the
CNCF
about and I think there were I don't
know if it was part of this question
that you had shared with me, but,
you know, because there's so many use cases
for containerd, there's the docker use case, the
Kubernetes use case, there's it's embedded in this
other vendor tool.
It's been hard to kind of cover those
broadly from
a documentation
standpoint.
And so we have been trying to get
more help to raise the level of documentation
that
can start with how are you using containerd?
Oh, you probably wanna start with API docs
or, oh, you wanna see how to configure
it in a certain way.
And so, yeah, bear with us. We're
we're trying to get there. It's an open
source project. So as you know,
it depends on the level of commitment from
folks. We've had people say, hey. I wanna
help with docs, and then they got busy
with other stuff.
So, yeah, we're still looking for people who'd
love to help us improve that area of
the project.
Alright. Awesome answer again.
We've got one final question.
And I'll read this one out, because I'm
not sure I understand this one. So someone
has asked if it is possible to transparently
use matters
for all kinds of registries.
Now they provide an example. They want to
use a pull through cache for Docker IO,
Quito IO,
the GCR repository.
They say that they have tried this in
the past. However, they run into problems with
certificates and authentication.
Is that something that has changed or gotten
better recently?
Yeah. I there has been I and I
don't know which
how
long ago or which version of containerd they
tried.
You know, containerd one four just came out,
which
I think one four is the
maybe the first version that has, like, a
rework of how you configure
registry
connections, I guess, is one way to say
it. But, you know, the
the, you know,
the certificates,
the authentication,
you know, which
order to to visit registries in when looking
for an image.
I just found an issue
from seventeen days ago,
containerd issue four five three one, if people
wanna go look it up.
But it it shows
some of the plug in configuration
for doing registry mirroring.
And so, definitely, it's supported in containerd.
It is a complicated area because, yeah, you're
you're having to set up a series of
registries and then all the authentication information.
I wanna say,
I hope it's a lot better in one
four than it has been. It's been an
area that we've
focused on. It may be an area where
we need. I I feel like I see
a lot of issues around this.
And it it also is a point in
time, so some
registry implementations
aren't really following the OCI spec well. So
we've been we've been trying to resist adding
tons of if else. Oh, well, this is
artifactory, and they do a four zero three
on this, and then you gotta respond with
this.
Or, oh, this is Docker Hub, and it
it has it expects
this series of of
events to happen.
So we've been
you know, we've had people from, you know,
GitHub registry
come work with us in the community to
make sure their
implementation
works with containerd, which they just
got the GitHub container registry working well with
containerd in the last month.
So it's a growing area, I guess, the
simplest way to put it.
If
someone's really stuck, please come to the repo,
open an issue
because there are people smarter than me about
kinda how the fallback and mirroring
configs work.
And then finally, hopefully, our documentation
keeps improving that you can, you know, say,
hey. Pull through cache. Where's the doc on
that? And how do I get it set
up? And, hopefully, we'll have a place
that gives you the lowdown on on making
that work.
Awesome. Thank you very much. We are all
out of questions. I just wanna say thank
you very much for taking the time out
of your day to join me. This has
been really helpful for me to help my
understanding of containerd.
I'm sure it's gonna be very helpful for
loads of other people. So thank you very
much, Phil. Yeah. Awesome. Thanks for having me.
No problem. Alright. Have a nice day, and
I'll speak to you soon. Thanks.
Alright.
Bye now.